how about it boy Apple sir [ __ ] yeah
no no no sensei matter we know we have
two words look what are you even
thinking we have to know what we're
working with before you no one is gonna
beat
oh that leg Oh make it longer click and
drag oh yes little ball that looks
delicious huh oh man the moon side
really more relative to it me Mommy I
got a haircut no no no I found a bug I
love that booty look at that little lady
look at our boy they're not yet not yet
talk dagger cow on a neighbor who later
that's that's a thing that's a choice
like the way his neck pops up as a way
to kind of mossy oh yeah looks like he's
been dead in a swamp great oh oh he's a
green on an option
oh oh he came out of the pit of hell
yeah that's exactly it for that's good
oh good I like that
I'm glad you're happy why you like it I
got a haircut right honey cause they
exploded from when he had testicles put
into them yes now yes please by all
means
oh please name him please what great
wisdom let's hear what will we got score
of 20 score of tawny scorched garb
Tony's Tony's gone
hello everybody did you look at the
bottom you got the button elevate right
hello everybody my name is Martin bar
and welcome back to spore you just had a
fun-filled
whatever finding get to explain any of
it so here we go we're playing again
loading tree ah I knew wow look at me
haha [ __ ] Nick we are ok so I got Tyler
I should have hit the button no you're
sure now I wasn't ready ok so now you
are on land and look it's your horrible
family attire their eyes flashing that
makes no sense but you're on land and
now you live amongst everyone you and
all the score tourneys so now you oh it
is the beginning of a new day and for
you a whole new strange and wonders
world blah blah blah whatever air fills
though you're now a land creature with a
great spiky booty I'm really glad you
pay attention those objectives okay do
it you're a carnivore hunt prey to eat
but you also can recruit other people in
your tribe i ones taking a poop oh it's
an egg never mind you you ain't no flute
you ain't good you got you got to get a
bone before you can do that
or anyway welcome back to the horror
after the horror of what no I'm just
kidding upside I'm messing around with
you it was a great joke I'm still the
worst yes you're still the worst
everything is right in the world way too
still door so what you trying to do is
trying to explore the place to find
bones to four parts let's have the bones
for farts those things don't look like
they deserve to live
yeah murder of all of them Edom get in
your aggressive stance red red red red
red red red red red Cal Cal Cal Cal kill
it lows okay laughs what do you what hi
what Oh friends who's this
you've met a new species no I got him
okay we know how to play the guy out of
my face Jesus
we played yes yes kill kill kill kill
all right I'll use your abilities you
got a spit press for four yeah one yeah
kill it kill it
you killed it great Oh things are okay
I'm not gonna be okay I know I'm not
gonna be okay hunt to spittoons you need
to kill two more of those things so do
that and all their friends and family
yes
kill it against it kill there have your
camera you can move your camera and move
at the same time spit at it yeah or kill
it kill it kill it
yeah okay yeah finally here's your
buttons yeah two and four or click on it
just keep plugging on it click away
whatever good you doing it you doing it
you doing it murder
don't let his back hit kill kill it's
killing you there we go oh now find one
more and kill it not that that's not it
kill the same species go back to the
nest go back to the nest you know
yeah no bones bones yes whoa then left
left it was on a hill do you remember
like the reality at it kill it okay
there you go yeah all right okay that
was fasted welcome back everybody for I
hope you enjoyed that really quick Tyler
here he's a quick learner he knows
exactly what to do and he does it right
away and that's a skill that I
appreciate you appreciate I appreciate
you appreciate that Tyler sir
gray Holloman we call him one-word Tyler
that's all he says ever so run away run
away run away run away run away run away
run away don't die please dear God below
I had so many times but it's still not
as frustrating as watching you die
welcome back everybody to Spore here we
are learning how to do everything again
cuz Tyler died happen stabbed the best
of us and he definitely is the best of
us so with that said but we're gonna go
we're gonna go we're gonna kill three
more monsters hopefully not die by the
end of it and then we're gonna evolve
again great you see those things down
there the four buttons one two three
four one two three four count you with
me it will be bored forwards ARDS to eat
up you need to build your strength young
man who do
turn your camera there we go
stop looking at the ground look oh there
we go
why you're doing day 9 all right my leak
which were there okay click on one of
them don't run up to him
look - oh you're too close all right now
back up look at that one in the bushes
it's so scared that had more backup more
charge it sorry I'm president oh good
that's good
a real good you did good there Preston I
try I feel like I'm setting him up for
failure but I'm really trying I'm really
trying here okay you did it great now
you need to have sex so that's can you
do that oh you need to go home that's
not a mating call ah someone banged me
yeah that's the way here we go so hard
press the hard part the hard part the
hard yeah hard ha ha people home should
know he forgot his glasses yeah you
can't see the TV is long all right you
got a question mark over what is what's
the question here what's the problem
what do ya Riley you're not your
characters like hey shake yeah I get it
yeah get good will you put your curries
like one I'm laying the egg yeah you are
the family oh yes I am taking a dump
that was
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been spore with Tyler and Wade
remember spay and neuter your pets go to
school
drink your milk have fun enjoy light one
word tile and listen to one word
Tyler's new soundtrack me see you the
next video bye bye
alright fine now I hate it you know
don't like I did it you murdered sweet I
know we're not opposing teams right now
but you have beautiful eyes